-You guys?
[ Cheers and applause ]
You can feel it.
I can feel it.
Spring is on the way.
The days are getting longer.
People are starting to make
their warm weather plans
and that includes
my Monologue writers.
You know, they write hundreds of
jokes every day
just to get the 10 or 12 we end
up using in the Monologue.
And honestly, a lot of those
jokes are not good.
[ Laughter ]
It's just we're being honest.
This is an honest place.
[ Laughter ]
And sometimes if we are
continuing to be honest,
I think they throw in a few
stinkers just to
fill the page
and meet the assignment,
but just because spring
is on the way
and birdsong is in the air,
doesn't mean you can
tolerate laziness.
Which means it's time for
another Surprise Inspection.
[ Fanfare plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-And let me just say
I would put our writers
up against any other
writing staff in the world,
I think they are absolutely
A-plus joke writers,
but you gotta --
I think the surprise inspection
is one of the things
that keeps them shipshape.
So here's how this works,
I'm going to read
some real jokes
submitted by my writers
that are unusable for the show.
Some are dumb.
Some are offensive.
Some are confusing.
Most importantly,
most importantly,
the writers don't know
we're doing this
and because a lot of them
don't watch the show,
they'll never know.
[ Laughter ]
So let's get started
with a real joke
that a real writer submitted.
Authorities in New Jersey
recently arrested
an alleged burglar after they
matched his DNA to saliva
that was found on the stairs
of the home he robbed.
And I'm just glad someone's
maintaining the drool of law.
[ Laughter ]
It's not -- it's too bad to even
be considered a dad joke.
It's like an absentee
father joke.
[ Laughter ]
Ian wrote it. Can we show Ian?
There you go.
That guy's just walking around
all cocky thinking like,
"Yeah, I nailed it today."
[ Laughter ]
A section of highway in --
a section of highway
in Alabama was closed yesterday
after a truck,
hauling 45,000 pounds
of chicken fat, overturned.
Experts are calling it the most
horrific schmaltz disaster
since the "Donny and Marie" show
got canceled.
[ Light laughter, groans ]
So that joke relies on people
knowing that
chicken fat
is known as schmaltz.
And then the next part of the
joke relies on people
thinking that "Donny and Marie"
like an act
from like 40 years ago,
were schmaltzy,
so it required
two things to work.
And even then, it doesn't.
[ Laughter ]
Brian wrote that joke.
Let's see, Brian.
There you go.
Brian, Brian was born in the
heyday of "Donny and Marie."
[ Laughter ]
An abandoned cargo ship
that contains more than
1000 luxury vehicles,
including Porsches,
recently caught fire
off the coast of Portugal.
Weird, I thought Lisbions
only drove Subarus.
[ Groaning laughter,
light applause ]
I mean.
Yeah, okay.
You know...
based on the first two,
that one's definitely
in the top three.
[ Laughter ]
Matt wrote that joke,
we should show him
since he got a smattering of
applause, yeah.
Oh, don't.
Don't do it, guys.
Alright.
A dog in California
was recently reunited
with its family after it
was missing for 12 years,
though if you ask me,
that could be any dog in there.
[ Sad laughter ]
Ali?
[ Laughter ]
See look -- yeah.
I heard Amber laugh,
Amber knows Ali,
and she's not
surprised by that joke.
[ Laughter ]
Today was the first day of Lent,
so ladies, right away,
I'm already terrified
that there's a "so ladies."
[ Light laughter ]
Today was the first day of Lent,
so ladies,
you best be giving it up.
Colin's?
[ Laughs ]
We got a, I think,
our first "boo."
That was a, there was
an audible "boo" in there.
Carnival Cruise Line
has announced
that beginning next month,
it will make masks
optional for all guests
and offer more flexible
pre-sailing
testing requirements.
They'll also be launching
a new fleet.
[ Laughter ]
You guys, you guys remember
that dog joke.
[ Laughter ]
You guys remember who wrote it?
Well, guess what?
[ Laughter, applause ]
They won't do my urn joke,
maybe they'll try casket.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, tomorrow
is National Grammar Day.
"When isn't it?"
said White people.
[ Laughter, applause ]
It's a Kelsey Grammer joke,
everybody.
Oh, yeah there's Colin.
Ah, you guys, that has been,
this has been
Surprise Inspection.
[ Fanfare plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]